[Music]
emma watson was perfect as belle
in the live-action remake of beauty and
the beast but what you might not know
is belle wasn't the first disney
princess that studio execs wanted the
british actor to play
emma was approached to be the lead in
the live-action remake of cinderella
of course lily james was cast in the end
that's because emma turned down the role
as cinderella just wasn't the right fit
for the actor who played hermione
granger but we're imagining just what
would have happened if she had taken the
part of cinderella
emma revealed that belle resonated with
her so much more than cinderella did
because the character is curious
compassionate and open-minded
[Music]
emma explained that belle is the kind of
woman she would want to embody as a role
model
she was inspired by the princess's
empowering defiance of what was expected
of her
[Music]
lily james said she put a lot of belle
and of ariel into her portrayal of
cinderella
she wanted to show that desire for more
in life to want to explore
as that makes them great role models
[Music]
lily originally auditioned for one of
the stepsisters
but once she started reading ella's part
she was totally
desperate to play her foreign
[Music]
if you think one live-action remake of
cinderella isn't enough then you'll love
this
sony is making a reboot with camila
cabello in the lead role
the singer will also be involved in the
film's music what do you think of emma
watson as cinderella do you wish she'd
taken the part
or is she better suited to belle and
what about camilla
are you excited for another cinderella
reboot please give this video a big
thumbs up if you love the disney
princesses
thanks for watching